hi everyone good morning thank you for
joining me today for the product School
webinar my name is namshin I'm a product
manager at eBay prior to being a product
manager in my previous lives I've been
an engineer ux researcher designer and
finally landed in the product world
it has been a wonderful learning
experience for me and I hope today I can
share some of those with you on
I will be talking about building a
product from the ground up it is of
course an extremely simplified
step-by-step guide but can also be
utilized at any phase of the product
life cycle
let's jump right into it
the way I like to break it up is in
seven different stages I go from
ideation to idea validation to defining
Solutions evaluating the solutions with
the users building an MVP launching the
MVP and then test learn iterate and
repeat the process
the first step to any product
development whether it is a new product
or an existing product we always start
with ideation
in this space we want to focus on the
problem space which means understanding
who the customer is and what problems we
are solving and why at the end of this
phase we need to have a very clear user
Persona in mind and the problem we want
to solve in the form of Harmony
questions
let's start with customers how does one
go about identifying customers depending
on where we are in the product lifecycle
we can utilize multiple methods to
identify our customers if there is a
specific problem space in mind we can
start by doing interviews user research
reading existing articles and reviews
doing reading online news we can also do
competitive research ask our users to
show us how they're solving the problem
today what are the different tools and
services they're utilizing things they
would want to improve upon and those can
really help us guide into the problem
space that we should be looking towards
and also help us understand our users
better
at the end we want to create a user
Persona where we identify our targeted
audience for the problem and their
struggles in the slide you can see that
there is a product School resources
which gives you a guide
step-by-step guide into how to create a
persona
this is an example of a Persona we have
information about the user's details but
also their goals motivation along with
their struggles there are many many
benefits of having a user Persona some
of them are it really provides a common
language for discussing users internally
within your team it helps maintain a
very user-centric mindset throughout the
design and development process it also
empowers rapid alignment when when we
are making early design decisions or
product decisions
as we have our Persona the next uh we
want to do is to Define what is the
problem we are trying to solve after
understanding and serving our users
struggles we have to land on a problem
uh we are focusing on and write how
might we questions the how might we
question statements um are small but
extremely powerful because it allows us
to reframe our insight into an
opportunity based on the user problems
that our targeted audience are facing it
really helps us give a direction to the
product Journey we can come up with more
than one multiple how might we questions
so the way to decide on which question
we need to focus on we can do a DOT
voting where everyone goes around the
room and reads the how might we question
and puts a dart board on the question
that they think we should be solving
towards
once we have the targeted users and
panelize the problem we want to solve
something that I prefer doing is
actually going back to the customers and
validating our assumptions
because often we can misunderstand or
misrepresent the information we get from
our customers I've had experiences where
we assumed a user is frustrated by the
number of clicks it took for them to
find a certain information but after
doing
more research and digging deeper into it
we realized that the information itself
was irrelevant that was bothering them
rather than the number of clicks or the
interaction it took so often we can
misrepresent and end up working on
something that the user does not want or
it's not the right problem space so it's
always good to go back to the customer
and validate our assumptions before
before we jump into solutioning
so what do we need to do is go back to
our users validate the problem space and
all the assumptions we have made it
could mean doing a quick check-in with
the users we have already spoken to or
going to a Starbucks and doing
interviews with people who might fit the
Persona that we are targeting or just
talking to colleagues who fall under the
targeted users but doing this validation
is very important before we jump into
solutioning
um while doing the validation it also
gives us an opportunity to ask more
questions to the customers and
understand how they're solving the uh
problem today and what are the solutions
they have in their mind that information
becomes extremely helpful for the next
space which is defining our possible
solutions
defining solution is an extremely
important but also fun process
um here we get to be creative and think
outside the box there are multiple
methods one can use for defining
Solutions my personal preference is
always starting with a team activity
session before doing any kind of design
work especially when we're focusing on
new problems what I like to believe is
five brains are better than one we have
done a few things depending on the
project one of them was doing a
brainstorming session with my team where
everyone gets a bunch of sticky notes
you write possible solutions on that
sticky note you put it on a wall
everyone goes around reads the solutions
you group them together and then you do
a dog voting to decide which solution we
would like to test out with our
customers
we can also do a crazy eight which is an
eight minute long process where every
minute we come up with a new way of
solving the problem this forces us to
break out of the regular process and
really push our boundaries to be
creative without overthinking this then
each person decides on the solution that
they would like to elaborate and the
whole team goes around looking at the
possible solutions and at the end we do
a DOT boarding to find the winning
solution
we can also do storyboarding where we
take the problem and create a scenario
around the problem and solve it in a
storyboard this allows us to create a
user journey and solve a very specific
problem while keeping the user in mind
and the specific situation they might be
in where they're trying to solve that
problem
at the end of each phase we want to come
together as a team and vote on the
solution we think are right for the
Persona and user problem we have
identified early on this really helps us
make sure that the entire team everyone
stakeholders who are involved in the
process are aligned in the direction of
the product that we are going towards
once we have our winning solution it is
time for us to evaluate that solution
the evaluation phase is broken into
three steps creating prototype testing
with users and repeating it until we
figure out what features should be going
into our MVP now I always suggest
starting with low Fidelity prototypes
for evaluation before going into any
kind of High Fidelity markups or
defining features for MVP
the reason for that is it's easier to
build it costs very less it's much
easier to make any changes so iteration
is much faster it really helps user
focus on the high level Concepts rather
than the details of the Prototype itself
it also helps detect and solve problems
at an early stage before investing a lot
of effort and money into building out
the solutions
there are multiple methods that one can
go about to create low Fidelity
prototypes one of them that I have used
a lot in the past is paper prototyping
where you can draw with freehand and
create working prototypes by just
changing one paper on top of the other
it really helps the user understand the
the product flow and help them focus
more on the high level goals rather than
the UI of the product itself
we can also have very simple wireframes
with boxes and circles it also gives a
very nice overview of the solution to
the user and they can understand what
happens as they click on one button what
pages can show up again really keeps it
very high level really focusing on the
um on the ux of the product rather than
the UI
next we can also turn it turn those
wireframes into applicable prototypes
with a lot of tools and softwares that
are out there it's still pretty low
Fidelity where we are using boxes and
circles to create that user flow now we
can make it clickable so that people can
click on it and really get the feel of
how the Prototype or how the product is
envisioned to work
once we have our prototype we need to go
back to the user and ask them to test it
and give us feedback we want to focus
more on functionality and high level
features rather than the execution
details for example in a previous role
we learned that users wanted to get
feedback from their clients on our
platform which means a communication
feature was missing whether it this
communication feature needs to be a chat
or an email does not need to be
identified at this phase
I like to iterate this process and keep
building a high fidelity prototype and
test with users
I also like to time box while building
prototypes to make sure that we are not
spending too much time and effort while
testing and getting closure uh closer to
the feature requirements we can use for
our MVP
which brings us to our next space
building our first MVP but before that
what exactly is an MVP
a minimal viable product is the first
version of our product that is
functional enough to solve the core user
problem and help us gather feedback
it allows fast learning and reduces cost
of failure it helps us get out of the
building instead of working on our idea
without any feedback and really get that
customer feedback loop going overall it
really minimizes the risk of building
the wrong product
for example an example of an MVP could
be that when the Airbnb Founders did not
have money to build an entire business
to validate their problem and solution
what they did was they created a very
minimalistic website and published
photos and details of their own property
and found that several paying guests
were willing to rent out their space by
doing this very small MVP test they were
able to find out that there is a market
for peer-to-peer
um apartment room sharing
now deciding what features need to be
part of an MVP can be difficult because
there are so many things we could be
building and doing for our users so to
keep ourselves on track and make sure we
build the right thing we can follow a
few prioritization methods
what I use is a prioritization matrix
understanding the low hanging fruit to
achieve the highest impact for example
here you can take all the different
features ideas and put them in this
Matrix of how much impact it's going to
make versus how difficult it is to build
a feature this allows us to identify the
low hanging fruits and prioritize them
this is especially very useful for any
kind of new product space
we can also use an impact versus urgency
metrics here you can take all the
different features ideas and put them in
a matrix of how much impact it's going
to make and how urgent the feature is
for the user to solve the problem that
they're looking at this helps
prioritization post MVB as well so it's
an ongoing process that we can utilize
after we have launched our first MVP
another method one can use to prioritize
features is the feature bucket here we
take all our features and we put them in
three different buckets the first one is
customer request these are features that
customers have been asking for these are
not necessarily a metric mover they
might not have the biggest impact when
it comes to launching an MVP or having
an impact on a metric but these are
something that we know people always ask
for then we have the Delights these are
minor but very attractive features such
as you know a unique sticker or an emoji
that can go on the App these are
delightful experiences but not
necessarily hard requirements for an MVP
then we have the metric movers depending
on what metric we are focused on it
could be user engagement it could be
customer satisfaction these are the
feature that is actually going to move
the needle for that specific metric
which means these features can also be
part of the minimal viable product when
we are launching it
other method that I have used a lot in
the past is the Moscow chart which it
has must have should have could have
will not have now this really helps us
prioritize our features into
non-negotiable product needs
um when we know that there's a specific
problem that we are trying to solve we
take a feature and we see that if we
don't add that feature to our MVP is it
not going to solve the problem is it
actually going to break the product that
we are working on if so it needs to be
part of must have now there could be
other important metrics that could that
are
um that that should be part of the
product or the feature but it
necessarily does not break the
functionality or usability of the
product so those features can go under
should have then we have could have will
not have these are features that are not
that important for the MVP and they can
be nice to have for the users so these
are bells and whistles that we can add
to our product but not necessarily
extremely important for the
functionality of the product itself
then we have the um counter model
analysis here we have threshold
performance excitement now threshold
these are the features that's going to
ensure the operability of your app or
the product and are the most expected by
users as well then we have performance
these features are mandatory but will
not substantially enhance the user
experience the third is excitement
features that users do not expect but
aim to guarantee the excitement or
generate excitement in a product now
threshold is the most important features
that needs to go into your MVP and it's
going to really make sure that the the
MVP is functional
lastly we have the user story mapping
user story mapping is a lean method
um we often practice it in agile teams
where we use sticky notes and sketches
to outline the interactions that the um
that the team expects the users to go
through to complete their specific goals
now we can have very specific different
problems that we are trying to solve we
can take all our features and see which
feature is solving what problem if a
certain feature doesn't fall under the
problem that we're targeting for MVP it
does not need to be part of the MTP it's
just another way for us to prioritize
the feature that we want to work on
finally all these different methods are
just to help us decide what features
need to go into the first version of the
product that we can release to our users
and get feedback
assuming we have done our feature
prioritization we know the features we
need to build we build the feature we
have our mdp now it's time to Launch
now there are many ways we can go about
launching a product we can do a
full-scale launch which means we we take
the product and we make it available to
everyone
we can also do a soft launch which means
we release it to a very targeted Niche
group of users to get their feedback and
iterate over it before we make it
available to everyone
if it's an existing product we can start
by doing an A B test where we have a
control group and a treatment group to
see how our feature or product is doing
in the wild in the hands of the user we
can also do an internal launch where we
make the feature available to our
colleagues in a lot of places I believe
it's called Dog footing as well where we
can expect our colleagues or team
members who fall under the Persona to
utilize the product and give us feedback
the overall goal is to present it in
front of the users and collect feedback
now one might think that this is it we
have launched but the most crucial part
of product development is creating a
feedback loop
now the feedback loop can be many things
we can do surveys we can do user
research we can do usability testing
there are many ways of going about it
but creating that feedback loop and
making sure that we talk to our
customers we understand how they're
utilizing the product and find the
problems that they are facing and
iterate over it is going to be crucial
for better product development
so that we can test learn and integrate
faster when products are in the wild and
users are using it in their natural
habitat and process it is the best time
to get feedback and create the feedback
loop
this is one of my favorite images that
one of my design Professor had showed us
in a design thinking class
Building Products is almost like playing
broken telephone sometimes we understand
our users but we can misrepresent what
they're asking for so it's always
crucial that we keep going back to them
for feedback or we can actually end up
building something that they did not ask
for
and so creating that feedback loop and
iterating and launching is crucial to
building good products and I hope this
guide helps you do that
as I mentioned it's an extremely
simplified process with seven steps on a
straightforward path but it is never as
easy as we think and we should always
expect somethings to go wrong we have to
go through a lot of hurdles a lot of
Hoops
um that we might not expect and it can
be a little bit more wavy but honestly
it's a lot more than that
um there are many many many processes
that I did not mention in that seven
steps um it could be you know
recruitment it could be users not
showing up to interviews it could be
going through a design review it could
be getting stakeholders alignment there
are many small bits and pieces that are
missing from that seventh step but
overall that's a very high level
um process that I have been following in
my career and I hope that that seven
step can fit into your product journey
and would help you kind of have
um
a sense of how to get from and just an
idea to building something that we can
actually put in front of users and see
them utilizing it
if there are any two takeaways that I
would love for everyone to get the first
is test early bail fast iterate and
repeat
um this is the Holy Grail of product
development where we want to test with
our users we want to learn from them we
want to fail and we should never be
scared of failing but we always need to
learn from our failure and iterate over
it
the second would be involving users as
early as possible our users our sounding
boards they are the people who are going
to use their products so we cannot get
better feedback from anybody other than
the users who we're building for so
enroll them as early as you can
um every step that we have discussed
throughout this presentation I have
linked to articles that can really help
you dive deeper into what each of those
different processes mean so I hope
that's helpful
um and if there are any few books that I
would recommend for PMS or even
designers would be the following books
um I have read all of them and they have
been extremely helpful in my product
management Journey product development
Journey the one book that I thought
really helped me with my process was
Sprint again and it's also a guide in
which gives you different steps of how
to go from an idea to actually building
something that we can test with
customers
um I hope this presentation
um has been this webinar has been useful
for everyone I would love to learn from
you all all the different processes that
you're using if there is something I
have missed please let me know please
share it as a comment and I am looking
forward to getting all your questions
thank you so much
[Music]